[Música]
buenas noches a todos
nací en argentina hace dos años y medio
este maravilloso país así que es gracias
lo lamento
ser breve
mi impulso más corto dura 6 horas
así que tengo 18 minutos hoy para
inspirarnos voy a dar lo mejor de mí
para inspirarlos en 18 minutos
y lo más importante son felices
[Música]
quien agradeció hoy cuando se levantó a
la mañana y abrió los ojos esta
comunidad
normal
quien agradeció cuando abrió la regadera
quiero agradecer lo que había agua
potable caliente
menos
quien agradecía el desayuno
que la reflexión la comida
tiene gracia venir aquí en un punto
y agradeció su ropa mientras asistía
somos un grupo muy pequeño de
privilegiados que tenemos en el planeta
hoy
pero estamos acostumbrados
a fijarnos en esa grandeza
por eso los cuenta estar felices
hoy voy a ser muy también mucha gratitud
porque soy muy importante
el camino de los herbicidas
nos enseñan a pedir
en vez de agradecer
y ahí se distorsionan todos
además de todo tienes una muy importante
es mucho tiempo de drogas conscientes
un espermatozoide inoculó invisibles al
ojo humano y sumieron guiado por una
energía divina
y el poder de la mente se puede mirar y
parece que todo
y ese lugar a ver si te doy
y si pasó esto voy a pasar los milagros
y eso pasó
gracias a una energía divina puedes amar
a dios universo mente suprema campo
cuántico de energía
o crees que fuiste tú
o tres que hizo llegar el espermatozoide
al horno este título
o queréis que hace que el corazón todos
los días
o creéis que así que trabajé ligado a la
construcción todos los días el estudio
no lamento decepcionar a algunos
es una energía superior que le puede
poner el que quieras
da igual
para calificar o menos
entonces siempre la duda
habilidad de habilidad vamos a hacer
muchos análisis
como tener 22 años de experiencia
vean muchas personas que nunca de atrás
cosas entonces encontrar
se construye y uno de los ladrillos
fundamentales para construir la
felicidad es ser agradecido
ahora vamos a ser una pequeña meditación
porque sentir la vibración
[Música]
con música voy a cruzar las piernas los
brazos
cómo
y cierro los ojos
y empiezo a respirar por la nariz
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y me conectó por lo que para mí es el
amor
[Música]
adiós
200 grados
y ahora de algo de mi vida
lo que tenemos
para mis seres queridos
[Música]
gracias
m
[Música]
celular
agradezco en lo que te voy a comprar
pero es futuro
[Música]
pero
atrás
me doy todo mi poder
[Música]
no tiene por qué ser distinto grado
[Aplausos]
[Música]
viendo
para dos minutos atrás
100 200 puede obtener ahora este
sentimiento de gratitud y cada día voy
aumentando más
las personas felices
alguna vez conocieron alguien
desagradecido feliz yo no
una porción al agradecido y feliz
sí
i
los días y me sentía bendecido no tenía
gas para cocinar
de poder
y tenía 21 años
nuestras primeras clases fueron el
turismo social prohibirá
en el proyecto
separadamente animales espirituales y
empieza a visualizar que miraba que
corría alicante corto
en cuatro meses
y luego se desplazarán las parteras por
haber perdido tanta masa muscular y
ahora empezaron
practique y nunca bajé los brazos fueron
siete años de búsqueda y práctica
[Música]
y
entornos piscinas de la reina del
kilómetro de sus piernas con mochilas
pesadas cuando nunca
la medicina voy a 3 y repito los
pronósticos y hoy enseñó a las personas
para que puedan despertar su potencial
esa potencia que todos tenemos dentro de
esa fuerza para poder servir al menos
para manifestar
la mayoría de personas están deprimidas
tienen ansiedad
y eso porque no puedes vibrar la
gratitud no puedes estar en dos
frecuencias a la vez no puedes estar
haber sido dejado es como estar en dos
programas de radio al mismo tiempo no
puedes
dos genios que dieron a este plan o de
milenios favoritos al verdad están
nicole antes y nada
nos dejaron un legado enorme sobre las
frecuencias
cuando una perita el protón quién es el
hombre más inteligente del mundo
cómo se siente ser el hombre más
inteligente del mundo
en el libro los empleos de la 10a
y tesla nos dijo si quieres entender el
universo tiene que hablar en frecuencias
vibraciones de energía en esos términos
toda esa energía de nuestro cuerpo se
energía el aire que teóricamente semana
ahora nosotros
moléculas átomos electrones que no
podemos tocar ni puedes ver ver esa
energía
y si tú libras en una energía alta amor
gratitud compasión el día se acabó one
una onda electromagnética de alta
frecuencia que va a encajar con la misma
cualidad iban a venir realidades
si te quedas estás el victimó al vacío
pierdo
esta ciudad de valencia pues se enseñan
a pedir nada a social ha pedido hacer
pequeños
hacer tomadores de arriba cariño
una vez más dios por favor de mi nombre
y hay herencia
la antigua forma de hablar era agradecer
de antemano lo que pasa que muchos
hombres situaciones los mensajes
nos enseñan a pedir y cuando tus vidas
el universo se siente que te falta algo
y te devuelve
esta misión
si todas la veces el día es una señal de
plenitud
entonces te vienen más situaciones
yo no aprendo y logré haciéndolos
yo enseño de nosotros
y sea cual sea la causa puedes pensar
que hoy
porque las religiones muchas cocinaron
buenas
siempre me visualizo como todos los
aspectos pero para romperlas eternidad
como adiós como un entrenador de fútbol
con como
y siento sobre mí en donde corre como un
dios
hay que valorar
otra vez
si lo después se volvieron olvidarlo
cómo conectar
como se hacía
una vez
meta
sólido del oro
500 años después jesús es el por favor
mejía
pero si fue para los hombres y todo es
pedir de rodillas
y los sistemas
por favor puedes recordarles lo que
vamos de nuevo
entonces es la llave que abre las
cerraduras la contraseña de muy fácil
para nosotros estar hasta afuera es
agradecer y en tu corazón
y tu mente
se alinea tu corazón y si empiezas a
visualizar
que eres feliz anticipadamente agradecer
tu plegaria como si ya fue escuchada la
antigua forma dura quiere como hace
aparecer de antemano lo que quieres
lograr tu mente se lo cree instrumento
que le da una señal al corazón que todo
está bien te apagaste a química de
estrés y genera única de felicidad
entonces tu cuerpo quizá cambiar tus
genes cambiando la expresión genética
modificados
i
y si te visualizas abundante cuando
ahora momentáneamente está pasando una
carencia tu cuerpo se lo cree envías una
señal electromagnética de gratitud de
abundancia de plenitud y eso va a tratar
con un imán
la situación es más común y cuánto bien
grave si tu vida que ibas a decirlo
y te conviertes en una persona que
ejercitó la lentitud y haber a veces
hasta lo más pequeño
y entonces ahí desde felicidad
y sólo con tu conexión divina siente que
no te hace falta nada y por consiguiente
no te hace falta nada tienes todo
no se puede estar ansioso y es que a la
vez no se puede estar triste desentona
vez
y cualquier situación niveles de ejemplo
puedo decírtelo hace dos años cuando
llegué a méxico mi hermano los grandes
aquí todavía
y yo no lo hago porque para mí
porque somos energía energía muere se
transforma
si puede servir agua en una pala y te
olvidas ese dorado que dices
nueva por el agua no dice segovia
mejor
cambio estado
entonces sin muerte
con paradigmas instantes con señoras
entonces
ya no estuve sufriendo yo estaba
agradecido
agradecido de todo lo que me enseñó y
llevaron adentro entrañar lo a
extrañarlo
dice que solamente cambio de estado
y amor
estás
entonces en cualquier condición tienes
que conectarte iguales
y de generar de adentro hacia fuera tus
cálculos
adentro se fuera a dominar los porqués y
vías esperando viviendo metas irradiando
que también es ya algo de falta
historias privadas y abre los ojos y
empiezas a grecia de lo pequeño a lo
grande te conviertes
y cuando me da resultado quieres
manzanas y más verdes y más general y
más ejemplo el para otros
y las recuerdas cómo se astado
nadie si a ser cambiado y quieres ver en
el mundo
se ha cambiado
[Música]
[Aplausos]
entonces a la socia de su vida
se arrastran recuperen la obra de arte
de nuevo
pero todo
y harán de ella algo para que otros
puedan verla inspirarse y poder hacer
dominarlos
así que yo le doy las gracias porque
estoy viendo su futuro
así que no sé por qué
ha logrado abundancia gracias por el
senado
y gracias a nosotros
agradezcan
tiene la seguridad
entonces
[Aplausos]